well about eight months ago tomorrow i
was in siena italy looking at this
painting in this room
that was the same day that italy went
into its quarantine just in the north
and the way those two are connected to
me is something i want to talk about
today inside the context of long-wave
cultural effects
first though you gotta see sienna this
is the first
landscape painting since the roman
empire it's also
the first or the last painting since the
black before the black death
but sienna has so much more going on
than that in 1260 sienna was a republic
that's the same time this pulpit was
carved reviving roman sculptural
tradition
and in 1310 it wrote the first
vernacular constitution
about the same time this 15 by 16 foot
altarpiece was developed
so what is going on that makes sienna
such a big deal it's actually
globalization from the mongols
who connect europe and asia and have
these trade routes and sienna goes in
for
luxury goods and banking you actually
see some silks and some tartar writing
there behind the virgin and the
altarpiece
but it's not like everything's all
sweetness and light in the world there's
still mercenary warfare and all kinds of
mayhem
and around siena and rebellion in siena
so this group of rulers these elites
called the nine
decided they better get some allegory
going on and they hire a painter and he
comes up with a plan
and if you script strip away the angels
a lot of it's kind of familiar
wisdom from heaven dispenses justice the
people agree there's a wise ruler
the nine and he provides peace peace
actually sleeps on
armor in that picture what happens if
there is no justice
well stop me if this seems familiar
there's tyranny it's a narcissist he's
full of selfishness
he's surrounded by these people who just
want to show discord and violence
and make life hell for everyone it's
terrible to live there
and if you're a 14th century christian
it's worse than that you're not just in
this lonely environment
where it's every man for himself the
only way you can live in a world like
this is to sin
which means you're going to go to hell
forever that sounds like a really bad
deal
what happens if there is justice in the
world well it turns out people work
together under justice there's community
and more than that the seven arts are
revived what god designed for us to work
and find meaning in the world so we can
ascend
even those theatrical dancers are
chasing away the worms of melancholy you
can see them there on the gown
well good mission statement the nine but
plague
comes in 1346 races across europe kills
like the dickens sometimes in just a day
wipes out 30 of the population sometimes
worse in places than others take for
example
sienna which lost 50 to 70 percent of
its population
in just a couple of years in fact it
didn't recover its population
until about 1950 which is one reason
it's such a great place to visit today
but then let's open on the lens a little
wider because the plague doesn't end in
five years
the plague actually goes for about 350
years flaring up every generation
or so people are arising and you know
hearing about these terrible deaths
somewhere near them
and this is a long wave effect that
changes the consciousness in europe
you start to see it very soon after
where there's an isolation
asia is a distant place we're not in
contact with anymore
we don't really know what's going on
there's an uncertainty and out of this
we create this new world of individuals
and it's not all bad because in the
renaissance we start celebrating
great individual artists and we um
thinkers as diverse as martin luther and
machiavelli
right against each other 150 years later
are talking about the individual and
god or the individual who's on his own
and how that creates the state
and they all have plague stories dig
deep everybody's got one
shakespeare's birthplace lost 20 percent
of his population when he was a baby
he goes on to event new emotional
experiences galileo relocates her rock
and newton's on a plague break when he
comes up with gravity optics and
calculus
modernity so there i am eight months ago
tomorrow having my dinner and thinking
about how all this came together
art and religion and politics
and just a couple days later something
kind of rhymes in history
that's right covid now covet is not the
black death it's not lethal like that
but i posit the covet is happening
during a new long wave what i call the
age of hyper awareness
where we have social networks and
science and
sensors and massive computation cloud
computing including my boss insert
virtual disclaimer here we virtualized
ourselves inside this pandemic with
fascinating and great results
but if we really have hyper awareness
maybe we can also be aware of history
and how we will change our consciousness
and be mindful of that
and remember that without peace and
justice tyranny and selfishness rule
and everyone's disconnected like say if
you politicize a disease and we all
start fighting with each other but let's
remember the other wall
and how some of the secret to life is to
find meaning and work in each other
to find each other essential let's bake
that into this new long wave of hyper
awareness
and hope for the best thank you so much
thank you clinton and what is the one
takeaway you want everyone to
to uh walk away from this talk with
history rhymes in beautiful ways
we can learn from that
you